thank you
oh God that's not okay okay just to let
you all know that this meeting is being
recorded and is going to be live
streamed on YouTube
um we need to agree the meeting held on
the 30th of March and I've had some
queries that have come up
um I'd like to go through them with you
um if we go to uh the first page which
would be item two
um counselor Mrs Christine Mason
um brought up an issue with regard to
the dating of original reporting now
I've actually spoken to Jeff about this
it's something that he will do on in
future to make sure that this is on
there's a bit of a misunderstanding and
in misinterpretation on this because it
should have been done this time but
basically when we go to the headings of
each item there will be a date on there
when it was originally reported so we
can actually get a good idea what's been
done and what hasn't been done and the
time differentials I hope that that's
fine with you uh Christine
yes thank you Ian that's uh exactly what
was anticipated thank you last November
thank you lovely okay and I think
there's another item that was missed off
and if we can go again on the minutes
um I believe this is pay will be page
three on your minutes and this refers to
hawkwell and it will be rectory Road
there was uh an item on there that was
bought up
um that should have been on on the panel
uh there should be two items in regards
to rectory Road
um can you just expand the second item
please Christine
foreign
it is nowhere near the first item
um it's probably the right oh it's by
Clements gate for people that know the
area
um works as the minutes that have been
carried out in that area
um which apparently resolved the issue
however the problem has returned
um and it's still there as of last night
the issue is still there so we need that
on the
um Regular updates okay
yes it's not being resolved even though
it's carried out okay thank you Ian okay
yeah if that can be actioned and put on
and can we also make sure that is
checked and ongoing please thank you
um and also uh I did mention to Jeff
that uh there was a a report on the main
agenda which isn't there which is uh
hawkwell Brook report which isn't there
and I believe you mentioned it was sent
out previously am I correct on this Jeff
uh yes yeah we've um there were a number
of related issues
um
which have been recorded sort of
individually but in fact they're all
linked to hawkwell Brook
um so there was a separate report done
relating to to Hawk Wellbrook which was
circulated with with previous minutes
um certainly if anybody wants to have
another look at that and and uh sort of
what I found there I'm I'm happy to uh
to send them a copy if you wouldn't mind
circulating that to the group as a whole
please so that they can have a look at
that report yeah I work with Veronica
and we can get that circulated
right I've got a mic you know you want
to come back uh you want to come in on
on something here
foreign
yes couple of items to pick up from the
minute yep under Rochford
um Saturn Road uh with regards to the
findings of the survey that was referred
to in the minutes there uh I've still
not received anything on that
okay uh so please can I have that uh um
organized the
some Paul wrote
um development there
um the slough skate flap that is missing
where the coal that goes underneath
ironwell Lane into the river roach yeah
and I am still trying to identify and
I've had no response from uh certainly
from County
um as to who is responsible for that
um sluice gate because it's missing and
the river can backfeed up through the
covert
um so again I'm still waiting for that
that information to come through are we
trying to identify responsibility for it
yes that's correct okay uh okay Jeff can
you try and do a bit of investigative
work uh to try and find out uh a deep
dive as to who is actually responsible
for it
yes I can uh I can sort of look into
that thank you okay and and a couple of
couple of others there
um High Street great way Korean
um again we we've been waiting for some
sort of survey or investigation it says
here
um to be carried out still not had any
information back on that who is the
responsible Authority for it like that
is I believe be highways
okay so uh again sorry Jeff
um if you can look into that
um to see if that work is due to be
carried out is there a schedule on it is
this um sorry is this relating High
Street
that's why I speak right wakering yes
the um I can comment on that the
um
yeah highways of of checked all their
assets they're fine
um the link seems to be where it drains
from the the highways sort of underneath
the recreation ground there and comes
out into it to uh uh sort of ditch at
the far side and I've been working with
the landowners of that ditch to get that
clear to help the the flow because that
seems to be what's holding it back from
and flooding back onto the highways
um so the the landowners have assured me
that they will do some ditch maintenance
work
um and I'll I'll sort of check with um
to uh to see they weren't able to do
that they even start thinking about that
until we came into September but
obviously uh yeah we're now into
November so I will check with them on
progress please if you wouldn't mind
um
yeah dad with regards to pointerest lane
or wakering Road Junction it was
fashioned because they were going to do
some highways improvements there and it
was hopeful that that would include some
work around the ditches that has not
been the case so the improvements have
been uh fairly minor and they have not
picked up on that particular point so
that is still an ongoing issue with the
uh ditches there uh if you can take that
one on board please Jeff to uh to get
the responsible people uh to to get
those cleared please
and finally but nobody's lease and uh I
will be declare an interest on this when
you get to the the point uh the
Kimberley Road the uh the the grill
there appears to be responsibility of
Rockford District Council and we've had
no confirmation as to who needs to pick
up the maintenance of that yeah if you
can check that one who is responsible
please Jeff
yeah that was sort of very uncertain who
was actually responsible but uh in the
past the council have sort of Taken uh
uh action about that so I'll I'll yeah
we'll see him again well obviously where
the people of last results so if you can
make sure that uh you know we're doing
something
um I've got Christine's hand up but I
just want to put in fact you can just
bear with me a lot of Christine uh Joe
is it anything related to the area that
we have been talking about please
um yes just to say when we uh cover the
High Street great white cream in the
formal document there are actually two
locations the location that councilor
Steptoe is talking about is slightly
different to the one that
um Jeff Stacey just referred to around
the ditch maintenance but they cover
them in the full papers and they become
clear thank you okay thank you very much
induja Christine can I come to you now
please
I think I'm slightly out of date now I'm
just going to say regarding the whole
book report it would be helpful if in
future if we have got a reference to a
separate report that is circulated at
the same time because not everyone
retains documentation so but thank you
for that so no problem okay that's
that's great okay uh so is everybody
happy uh with what we've got in the
minutes and and those can be agreed
inside
can I see an indication please agreed
yeah with the alterations of course yeah
of course of course
lovely thank you very much all of you
um now Declarations of Interest please
members if I just go through Mike I'll
just take you on the screen as you are
Mike any thank you uh yes Essex County
councilor also is Barling Magna Parish
councilor and also I need to declare
that the stream that arrives at the
bottom of Kimberley road we were just
talking about
um ultimately Upstream does run through
my garden okay what fun
um Joe if I can take you please
I have no declaration in my hands now
yeah
have you
okay Christine
yes thank you just in case it does come
up hawk or Brook runs behind my property
I'm not sure that it's something we're
discussing today but just in case we're
stray into that area obviously I'd have
a direct peony interest thank you okay
thank you and Joe
um any declarations at all
no you've asked for declaration stuff
any who have any will part their hands
okay okay thank you uh Lorraine
[Music]
yeah I'm also an Essex County Council
I'm Deputy uh cabinet
um for highways maintenance
okay thank you uh Chris
yeah just uh lady Tech Council thank you
very much okay and Stuart
uh none for me thank you okay and for
myself it's radio channel Council and uh
as a non-procuniary and a pecuniary
interest in Rochford hundred golf club
and that's me done
uh if anything comes up during the
meeting uh please shout out if you think
you've suddenly discovered an interest
okay Moving On Let's uh move over to
item four which is a review of what is
going on okay Jeff it's over to you uh
to go through these and I will watch out
for any hands that have come up and I'll
stop you for questions okay away you go
Jeff
okay
um
first uh just to to sort of uh make
everybody aware uh we will have somebody
from the environment agency joining us
later Unfortunately they had a a sort of
clash for the beginning of the meeting
um but if there are any questions that
relate to the environment agency uh
Roger Webster will be joining us later
in the meeting
um and and uh you know sort of please
ask your questions then
um Essex highways uh they are unable to
attend the meeting
um but um
uh they have given me some notes uh and
and sort of comments which I will bring
in as as we sort of go through here uh
can I just make a note please I'm not
happy with Essex highways not attending
uh Richard baronovsky always used to
attend or attend someone in his stead
and just to send notes on some of these
things because they're often follow-up
questions that members want to ask so
would you just please make a point that
I'm not particularly happy about him
coming uh not coming and and the simple
fact when it was live he always used to
be here now it seems to be more
convenient and online he can't seem to
be bothered you know I think this should
be an item that he he needs to take note
of and him or one of his deputies should
be here at least to answer questions
relevant questions
yeah I'll certainly pass that on and I
mean to be fair to Richard he he's very
supportive I know yeah but but the um
yeah the decision not to attend has been
taken sort of uh further up the the
management chain
um but certainly we can feed that back
okay can I ask Essex County councilors
who are sitting here to inquire who that
up the chain person is please
Ian I did actually send um because I
thought Simon was um going to be on the
uh this meeting I did send him the
actual reply from Essex highways so I'd
um I do apologize I didn't send it I
don't know I think I said it I don't
think I said it to Jeff but I did send
it to Simon um and if I can find it I
was over to you now okay Ariel you came
on I I'm not I'm not sure enough I Know
Who You Are
hi yeah my name is Ariel I'm just
sitting in for Glenn Shaw today because
he wasn't able to attend on the llfa
okay thank you so I'm quite new but I'm
I'll take any notes back to Glenn okay
um are you able to share the screen at
all uh Jeff or are you having problems
or uh or maybe Veronica
can can share her screen with the um
item four so as we go down it or has it
has everybody got that item for in front
of them if if you've got any problems on
you and you're okay we're just leaving
it as it is I'm happy to carry on
because I've got it in front of me
we okay everybody okay yeah yeah okay
thank you thank you all uh okay so let's
start off ashington
yeah
um no particular update on that
um the comment from from sorry the Essex
highways
um is that yeah basically the the
situation is unchanged for them
um if there is further evidence of
flooding please let them know and then
they can they can sort of uh help build
that that case for any work that needs
doing
um but at the moment there's there's
nothing planned okay that's the Lower
Road ashington Road uh Priceline
uh brace Lane
um
yes that was being looked into by the
Essex County Council what Watercourse
regulation engineer and in fact that was
uh Glenn who's been unable to to join us
I've heard nothing further on on that
one
um I don't know if there's anybody's
aware of any
uh further problems uh Aaron certainly
there was no issues when uh when uh they
did do a visit Ariel have you got
anything on that at all please
foreign
um no no update for Glenn didn't provide
me with an update on that so I assume no
news is good news
I wouldn't assume anything like that at
all
okay if you could just take that one
back just to give a nod because we like
to see an action to come back so please
give Glenn you know a nudge to come back
to Jeff on This one thank you okay yeah
I'll check with him see if there is any
further interaction but certainly as as
sort of reported there
they did visit the site and didn't find
any evidence of uh sort of filling in
the ditch by the developer okay
um so I'm not sure there's you know
unless there's any further reports
uh of flooding
um that we can follow up on I'm not sure
we can go much further with that one
okay that's fair enough Jeff uh Lou's
close to high cliff present
uh yes the um uh
that one seems to sort of be bouncing
around uh in terms of whose fault it is
but uh uh Essex highways have have uh a
sort of
um check their assets
um and feel that it's angling water
um you can get water unfortunately
haven't joined us in the meeting so I
think we'll have to uh chase them after
the meeting for a comment
on uh their assets
um because certainly that seems to be
where the where the problem lies yeah uh
I I again it's the same same story we
need to get everybody in the same room
at the same time and I would be obliged
if we can try and get people from
anglian in the room it's not a big deal
just to come in turn up for two hours
try and get it together to send someone
along who can just take responsibility
for what they are doing that would be
most helpful if you can send something
to them you know we'd be much obliged if
they would uh be helpful as far as
that's concerned
okay I mean normally David Lloyd who's
our contact there yes yeah yeah yeah
helpful but um obviously he's not joined
us in the meeting yeah it would be I
mean this is the whole point of this
meeting is that you know supplementary
questions you know can come up and it's
good to get the answers there and then
rather than going backwards and forwards
it's uh it's pretty pointless to be
honest
um if we can move on to 621 ashington
Road please
uh yes
um highways comment there obviously
they've done some work in in that area
they've received no further comments of
issues there and uh I've not picked up
on anything so unless anybody is aware
of any issues still existing there uh
really that we're sort of archiving that
one so to speak okay okay
uh moving on to battles Bridge
uh yes the um there were some issues
sort of reported there
um but uh highways were sort of not
aware of uh any any particular issues
and basically are asking for uh sort of
reports and evidence of any issues there
to which uh so far they've not received
anything
um whether that might change over the
coming season
um but our our request basically is if
if there are issues
um if they can be reported let's have
some details photographs if possible and
uh they can then go up to highways
um just a matter of Interest Chris was
this one of yours to report in because
it's out towards your area isn't it
yes it is Ian uh and you're quite right
what you've just uh committed on on on
representatives from the uh utilities
um yeah um that was bridge at the moment
um is okay apart from the lock gates at
the end of Forest Brook where it runs
into the Crouch
um I I think there is uh there's there
is some confusion there as to whether
the gates are open or closed at times
when we've got at the moment I know it
sounds silly and then it really really
does but when you're in raw riff and you
see that won't come up it's it's quite
quite phenomenal
um but anyway
um yeah there is uh some we I need if we
could or if I could be told or the
residents could be told when the gates
are if the gates are permanently open or
what what is happening because they've
got no idea they have to keep going down
there to see if the gates are open to
let the water out basically who's
supposed to be managing those Gates
um it I I think it's the uh well I don't
I don't know his name exactly but I
believe it's the ownership of the the
people that on that area that they
control the gates I I don't know if it's
a better world with Roger Webster about
it um he he considers it that there
isn't any problem at all but okay fine
look I may be just just so we can sort
of firmly establish who does what where
and how Jeff if you can try and
establish who monitors the gates who who
opens them who closed them or who is
supposed to open and close them then you
know and get something a wee bit more
definitive on that one Jeff and then we
can move on to canoe
yeah okay I mean it may be that when
Rogers Webster joins us later in the
meeting he may be able to answer that
one okay that's good okay knut and I
think this is part of laureen's uh
backyard yeah
and canuden the I did follow up with the
the the the sort of Parish Council
because they um
uh we didn't have a sort of location
um details for the for the issue
um but when I did update with them they
said that the work had um they confirmed
the work had been completed and there's
there's not an issue at the moment
um because on on that one yeah that's
correct Ian
great thank you for that thank you for
that Lorraine
um canoe Gardener's Lane
yeah again I I popped out and had a look
at that had a chat with the uh the sort
of Parish Council there
um just to sort of try and understand
that
um I noticed when I did the visit that a
lot of ditch maintenance uh had been
carried out by the landowner
um I think pragmatically what I've
suggested to the
to the parish council is if the problem
reoccurs
um with flooding of the of the road
there
um it just seems to be a question of uh
sort of digging a a sort of ditch way
from the uh you know just a a small
Channel
um from the road into the ditches which
have now all been cleared
um would would sort of clear uh water
from that that road so really we're sort
of waiting to see whether a problem
reoccurs and and whether yeah somebody
just sort of going down there with a
spade
um to uh to link in the the road uh to
to those ditches
um
so we put it onto the parish council you
know in a pragmatic way uh to look after
their area is that about right is that
sum that up yes I think that does okay
good stuff uh
um
yes and sorry I haven't I haven't
apologized the for some reason the uh
Zoom is not picking up my camera so it's
uh
a technical issue then
yeah certainly the the plow and sale
um obviously this is a long-term ongoing
issue
um I have got uh some comments from uh
Essex uh highways on the surface water
alleviation scheme
um they are attending on a regular basis
last attended
on the 13th of the 7th and the 14th of
the 10th
um
uh this was raised uh they've raised us
with angling water discussing the
possibility that they may be able to
connect to an existing anglian water
infrastructure in the area
although not the foul sewer
um the design team were therefore
commissioned to review the existing
design based on the potential of this
new information
however on closer scrutiny the design
team at Anglia water were unable to come
up with anything new
um so this scheme is now waiting for the
design work
okay okay uh if you can just keep an eye
on that I know I know Mike has got his
eyes on this and has I think he bought
this one up what about eight years ago
it was Terry cutmore yeah yeah
because of the sad loss of Terry but yes
it is doreen's uh Division and uh very
easy place I don't I don't have anything
further no no fine no thank you uh Acton
Hall Road
um Hampton Hall Road
um
yes the the
a new the the sort of landowner as uh I
sort of followed up on this one too to
see what was happening
um and it has been resolved with a new
pipe at the front of the property to
replace the field in ditch
um and there has been some maintenance
work by the landowner and that all seems
to be working so we're we're
no further action sort of uh planned on
that one okay just quickly uh just a
note on the bottom we've got lead agency
you've got nothing on that one and
Laureen please just to let you know I
went down that way yet today just see
what the road was like and it was
absolutely clear fantastic thank you
yeah see uh Jeff if you can make sure
that we have Legion the lead agency uh
noted on there whoever they may be so if
it's residents Liberian owner or
whatever if you can make sure that's all
there so we know yeah I can certainly
certainly reflect that for for future uh
reference
um so that should there be an issue that
comes up again we've yeah we know who we
should be talking to that makes sense
yeah yeah thanks Jeff uh hawkwell I
think this is your backyard Christine
yes I'm waiting to take your breath yes
Clement's hallway
um
yes the the that's one of the ones that
um
there seems to be a number of issues
along the the sort of Fort well Brook
catchment which uh I've sort of captured
in the report there
um in terms of one action we can we can
take on that
um
I mean I really would is is sort of
waiting until we get somebody imposed to
uh
is more of a a sort of engineer
um drainage engineer and know something
more about this
um
having identified what some of the
issues are I must admit it's it's not
within my sort of knowledge or remit to
sort of take this on further
um we're really sort of waiting until uh
uh somebody is imposed to who can sort
of pick this up and try and run with it
okay can you just hold on a second then
Jeff
um Andrew uh um I don't want to dump you
in this one but obviously I believe we
do have somebody who will be joining us
uh that will be uh mutually part of the
one team from both Brentwood and
Rochford who will be a specialist in
this way if you confirm that please uh I
don't I don't know uh you don't know us
yet okay all right but I will uh take
that back and make some inquiries thank
you because I mean Jeff is uh is
actually stating that we're looking at
an experienced engineer who will be
working across both the borough and the
district so that'll be very useful
thank you I mean certainly at this stage
it uh I mean that's literally sort of
hot off the press that the The
Proposal was only agreed a couple of
weeks ago
um so so there is a long way to to go on
this and in the meantime I will sort of
continue to do to do what I can
um but taking on something which which
in effect is a sort of major project
um wouldn't be sensible for me to start
a because it's not my area of knowledge
um and B I certainly wouldn't be able to
to make any significant progress before
we brought in somebody who who would be
better qualified to to sort of deal with
that okay thank you
but at the moment yes the we're drawing
up uh you know sort of proposals for a
new post
um and uh yeah that will go forward in
due course yeah if we can make sure that
that's hurried along
um
um
yes made some inquiries on on on that
um
yes it's sort of private ownership uh
certainly we haven't had any uh sort of
further reports of of flooding
um but our response would be that that
uh you know it's down to the local
landowners in terms of Maintenance of
local systems Christine would you like
to add to that please well actually I
wanted to come in on Elm Wood Avenue
because that was
is an RDC responsibility and the concern
there is
um the cow that goes underground at that
point and what happened at the time was
because the growing the grid got blocked
and the Carver got blocked
um properties further down the road
actually in Hawthorn Chase were flooded
quite severely and
I'm not sure if my Elwood Avenue I think
one or two in Elmwood Avenue was where
when they opened their doors
unfortunately but
um
so it's definitely needs to be kept
clear and at that time it was deemed to
be an RDC responsibility so regardless
of any report it's something that we
have a duty I think to ensure that that
whether the is a ditch that goes from
belchems which takes the water and then
it goes underground and it's at that
point
that um that there is an issue and I
think that should be looked at in view
of the weather reports that we have now
and the potential risk to property I
think that should be looked at by RDC as
a matter of urgency yes if you can put
that on the list to go uh to Adam
Aldridge because I know he's I've
already spoken to him this morning about
Noble's green ditch which is part of the
roach
um looking at the maintenance and
apparently they're having to look to
Essex County Council because of the
changes in highways and ranges and all
the rest of it for permission and
insurance which I I'm not too sure about
but uh he's he bought that up so we want
that squared away as soon as possible so
if you can uh put that one on the list
please Jeff
to look at maintenance on that area if
that is ours then we need to do it
I think at the timing and just for
Jeff's information there's a gate to
that so the residents can't actually
access it but the key was given to the
resident who it was unfortunately since
moved so I'm not sure what the uh
current situation is okay uh Jeff if you
can take note of that because if you
want to go without without no new Chris
you've got your hand up yes please see
and could could we ask if to reaffirm to
the right parent owners that it is their
responsibility to clear the ditches uh
please yeah yeah absolutely I think that
is a standard uh but we will make sure
that we're we're feasible where possible
um they they are there to keep their
areas as clean as possible to allow the
water flow I agree with you Chris
absolutely thank you and Christine
anything more I could just say that this
I've had no recent reports of the
surface water on Hollywood uh Oakland it
was at the junction of Mount beavers and
Woodside Chase so I'm hoping that Jeff's
right and that was cleared and do you
want me to speak to rectory mode or I
might as well
yeah I know we've got this one coming up
rectory road is coming so if you want to
speak to that and then maybe Jeff can
come back straight after
yeah directory Road well I can't comment
on the low-lying area under the Railway
Bridge although that's historic it's
been like that for about 50 years
um but the one that's been missed out is
the one by Clements gate and that is a
potential District
difficulty that's been reported
um way back with Richard satin bear been
it's over 12 years old and a despite
work having been carried out it's still
not resolved so that needs to go back on
there yeah thank you yeah okay
um if you can put that back on the
agenda Veronica that's Clement's gate
and the surrounding area
sorry if I can just clarify it is
actually rectory Road
adjacent to the old entrance to what
then was the Christmas tree farm yeah
that locates it thank you very much
Christine thank you okay
um anything to add on the rectory Road
Jeff before we move to belchamps
a comment from
highways the uh the cyclical there's
there's a crew that goes around on that
on a cyclical basis
um and now they try to attend on the
the last time was the 25th of March 22nd
but
they were unable to access there's a lot
of difficulty obviously there with
traffic management and things
um so it it is on the the route for
cyclical maintenance but um they do have
difficult with traffic difficulty with
traffic management there
can we get an idea of what the
difficulty is is it just weight of
traffic
uh yeah I think so I think it's just the
volume of of traffic there but I can
certainly ask for more details from
um
a bit more on this area
well the Clarence won by Clement's gay
in rectory Road
this is where it goes underneath the
Railway Bridge I can't Enlighten you
with that other than to say that it's
been the same situation yeah in my
lifetime I've lived in my life so I've
never seen any different okay thank you
so we need to make we need to try and
see if some action can be taken
um and if it's an inconvenient
scheme a traffic management scheme as
long as people are aware of what they're
doing and that they carry it out quite
quickly I you know I'm just going to
hope for the support of our County
colleagues who are sitting here to try
and get the how can I put it a little
bit of dynamite underneath the so to
speak
uh
Bell Champs
anything on that at all Jeff
uh no the the
um
some time ago I did a visit there to
sort of have a look on how the the whole
thing
um sort of uh works out and it it is all
part of of this Hawk world you know the
whole hawkwell Brook
um and that it all there are a number of
issues along the length of the whole
Quail Brook which contribute to
difficulties there
um
yes there is if we could if we're some
future stage can look at a bigger
project there are possible contributions
that the um Bell Champs could make to
improving the flood resilience
um within hawkwell Brook but as I say it
needs a greater level of expertise than
than I have to uh to to put that sort of
project into place okay thanks Jeff if
we can move to hot clean now Corn Hill
Avenue
um
yes I mean as the the latest information
is is there on the um on on the sheet
um earlier this year
um there was a site visit that was
um uh sort of unable to to sort of
identify as a definitive cause it needed
a professional in investigation
um which has been arranged I don't know
if that's taken place yet but we're
certainly still awaiting the report
um last update I had on that was in
September
okay but it's us who are the lead Agency
on that item
um Folly Lane well I mean just there
it's it's we've taken the lead on
finding out what the problem is yeah
um once we know then it may be another
lead agency comes in but yes at the
moment we lead on that one okay that's
fair enough
um fully line
um yes I
I've done a site visit and sort of had a
look trying to get my head around where
the the issues sort of Link into uh into
this
um
and there is a local Resident was taking
some action to improve the drainage
um and and I have sort of spoken to to
her about that
um I've had no further reports although
I haven't followed up with that that
Resident so I'm not sure what the
conclusion was to that I don't know if
anybody's aware of any further issues in
that area I know that um as we go along
Hockley
um there are a lot of subterranean
streams I mean a lot of subterranean
streams as well as the Overland streams
that run through a district and
um I mean one of the things that
actually gives a possible clue to
flooding is uh Pond Chase I think the
word Pond may be a clue uh to as to why
there could be some problems in the area
but I think there's a lot of you know
Subterranean streams that run through
which pop-up as ponds and various other
things that when we've had development
and this is another problem
we are not completely aware of all these
underground streams they haven't been
mapped properly that's another problem
maybe we need an expert to come in but a
lot of the mapping has disappeared I
know some of the action mapping does
show it but we do realize that you know
we are pretty ignorant in places where
we're agreeing to some developments that
we don't realize that we're on top of an
aquifer which is a problem and and
that's something again plumro Avenue uh
this is a problem that's occurred here
any updates on that please
yeah I mean just to sort of finish off
well in fact to sort of pick up on the
comment that you've made there on both
of those
um
certainly that there was a project being
run by Essex County Council to map
um all these sort of ditches and drains
and and everything else
um that project is is uh
sort of fell off because of change of
staff and things but they're they're
looking to to sort of reignite that a
little bit
um and uh sort of encourage activities
to then feed in so that there is a
central
uh electronic map on a geographic
information system to map all these
things
um so hopefully that is is is something
that if that that project is reignited
that we can start feeding into
um and start sort of picking up
information and trying to get it in in
somewhere that we can refer to
uh I've got Dave Chapman here you're
going to add to this knife
yeah so Jeff is right there was a where
does water go project that was run a few
years back where we encourage Parish
councils anybody that had a knowledge or
an interest in an area
um we provided uh information packs for
people to go out and recording assets
and information pass it back to us it
would be then digitized so we could keep
a copy of those that is being
um brought back to life so there is
um a willingness from us to do that
again if there are interested Parish
councils individuals Charities you know
front action groups that want to take
part in that that already haven't then
contactless Council on can put the email
address in the uh in the chat if that's
easier for everyone and then just
contact us as and when they uh they'd
like to sort of re-engage with us on
that Dave can I just ask
um have you uh have anybody there
contracted
um the Records Office and so
uh with regards to I think old Maps so
we we do where you look at site-specific
um requirements where we've got a
request in or we've got an interest or
an inquiry we will contact them as as
and when we need to we will also do
background checks on history and old
maps online things like that we also
have public rights away Essex highways
that we can contact as well so we do
them on a site-specific basis but yes we
do do that okay thank you very much Dave
uh Mike you want to come in uh yes just
picking up on what they've said about uh
information going out to Parish councils
speaking of the parish council I can't
recall receiving anything in our
particular Parish Council so perhaps I
should we should suggest that uh this is
re uh sent out to Parish councils
um and just to get them back on online
with it they're just historical
knowledge thank you very much Mike yeah
if you could do that David that would be
really good
um okay moving on Jeff uh Westminster
Drive
uh
yeah Westminster Drive
um
yeah the Rocha District Council of
um
taking responsibility on that one uh
contract has been appointed to undertake
the work
um yeah we're just waiting for a date
for that
Christine you happy with that
well really
um I was hoping they'd be more positive
information because the resident
contacted me I think it was about a week
ago and that they had been advised the
work would be completed in October and
at that time it hadn't been done
um we're now Midway through November I
was hoping that we'd have a more
um up-to-date report because it was if
it was a bit delayed we want to know why
and when because obviously flooding is
more likely to occur in these coming
months so perhaps Jeff could find out if
that's been done
because I need to feed back to the
resident I mean that this has been going
on for some considerable time thank you
I I am absolutely wondering if this is
the same problem that that I'm incurring
uh you know having with with Adam saying
to me with the changes over with
highways uh and the Rangers and they
need to know everything that's going on
everybody who's doing whatever uh that
we were able to manage just as we did
this has all changed and they have to
have an audit on everything I wonder if
that's holding it back and the insurance
issues that he raised is this is why
um Noble's green and the other items are
being held back because of this
if you can check on that please
understanding from the resident was
purely that the contractor
just decided for reasons unknown to
delay the work but I don't know why I'm
afraid I would I I would say we need to
get to the bottom of this in regards and
get this sorted out because I'm sorry
you know we can't have this constant
changes we've got an arrangement that
was in and all of a sudden it all all
changes because Essex wanted it to
change to something else and it's really
how can I put it matched up what was a
very good working system so Jeff we need
to put that one down and we need to
clarify that completely because this is
ridiculous we can't have this yeah I
will kind of find that one but I think
in this case it's this one is not um
not one relating to the work that Adam
does but is is purely an asset
management
um however pointed the contractor okay
so so I don't think that's affected by
the same issues that you've highlighted
there but I will follow up on that one
thank you I would agree with that Jeff
yeah thank you thank you okay moving to
holbridge
yeah watery Lane
um
I mean as is down there the comment um
that I've got through from from highways
um their last visit they last attended
on the 11th of the 7th
yeah
um
and did a substantial substantially
cleansed and and they're sort of
continuing to monitoring the attend as
required
um and they will do another
preventative cleanse again next year
um so they've sort of upped the the sort
of maintenance schedule on on watery
Lane uh I mean we we accept that that
you know because of its situation is is
going to flood but they're just trying
to improve the uh maintenance on the
drainage there so that it it clears
quicker each time okay so they have got
a regular maintenance system that
they've now put in place yeah yeah okay
keep that one monitored make sure that
they do actually do it going on to
malians
um I I do have knowledge of this one I'm
sure Stuart as I've been out there to
see what it was all about uh you've got
lead agency empty again on that one uh
would that be anglian water
um well well there the
really the the conclusion that we drew
was that it was nothing to do with the
drainage from new development or
anything like that awesome correct it
was it was down to to sort of
Maintenance by
um residents
um of of a ditch that that sort of run
along the back of their Gardens which a
number of filled in was was really what
it came down to
yeah yeah anything to add Stewart on
that one because it's your belly Wick no
I mean it's definitely not coming off of
the um the new development and that is
what Jeff's just said is my
understanding as well yeah thank you
very much okay uh the Dome
uh yes I mean really we're working with
the lead local flood Authority we we
sort of reported back on that in terms
of uh sort of what the issues were and
responsibilities
um working with the sort of environment
agency and others so that we could sort
of fully understand what the issues and
the risks were there uh and and there
was a separate report uh sort of back on
that
um we have asked
um although it's a landowner
responsibility they're they're proving
difficult to sort of trace and and get
some response from
um so we have asked the the people who
maintain the two sites the two Caravan
sites there if they will help
um and certainly I noticed when I went
past the other day that um the the main
ditch along the the front of the site
has now been cleared
um and sort of some sort of pardon me
some substantial maintenance has has
been done there
um the highways agency comment that uh
uh they've
um yeah again their cyclical crew go
around
and do maintenance on there it's been a
while since they've done some but but
you know there was no problems with
their assets there that was that was
sort of working
um
I mean really on on that one there's
there's no
sort of further particular action that
that is being proposed there were
questions on things like the
um where the water drains through the
the sea defenses and things like that
but that although there were concerns
there by by the sort of residents and
things that was checked and found to be
working fine okay so Chef going on to
hold Bridge Road opposite lubbard's Farm
um
we're still really the the although at
some stage that has been reported as an
issue we've asked for uh further
information on exactly what the issues
were and where the flooding's occurring
um and have not got back any comments
yet so we're not aware of any particular
issues there unless anybody has further
information
okay now I've seen our hands okay
Grasmere Avenue and the drive
um yeah again this was a another one
where uh it's the ditch runs uh along
Gardens
um and uh it was a sort of Maintenance
issue for local residents
um but as a gesture of Goodwill
Rochester District Council came in and
did that and we've heard no further
reports right Kings Kingsman Farm Road
um
again asking for further information and
reports on what the actual issues are
there and nothing's been reported okay
uh Stuart can you help us on that one
now is it
um Jeff is is this where the
um existing Caravan Park is at Halcyon
where they're putting in the new
Caravans there
well I'm really not clear which is why I
sort of asked for further information of
where the flooding issues were
um and and nobody seems to know
yeah I mean I think potentially if there
was um a new Culvert put in there and as
far as I know there's been no flooding
down there
yeah and it could well be the events
have overtaken
um because I picked up when I sort of
came in to to helping with this
um I tried to to pick up some of the
historic issues so that we had this list
all it all in one place that we could
refer to
um but some of the historic information
I was picking up on was was less than uh
than helpful so it could well be that
events have overtaken this one okay okay
thanks a lot for that thank you Stuart
um moving on to Riley
first item Boston Avenue Culvert I know
this is a century housing item I think
that's raw efficient is your ballywick
isn't it Chris
uh yes Ian uh first of all can I can I
say a few words to David Chapman on the
uh works that he is progressing with uh
Rory a very very applicable
are you listening David and I think
Chris wants to chat with you no I don't
want to chat I just want to know that uh
that he's doing a very good job there um
unfortunately the weather is against him
at the moment to finish it off but
nevertheless um the the works that are
being done are very admirable thank you
very much David
um with relation to some of the other uh
things that uh around our or my district
my world
um
can we stick with the agenda and we'll
come to it in a minute is that okay
Chris yes yes that's fine sorry yes yeah
fine lovely okay so uh Boston Avenue
Calvert it's being looked into is that
right well well the the concern there
was was maintenance
um of the the stream coming into the
Culvert and the Culvert
um we we tied that down to uh the covert
the surrounding areas responsibility of
sanctuary housing yeah we've made
contact with them uh they've said there
is a sort of maintenance schedule which
they have to agree with the the sort of
environment agency and can only do it at
certain times of the years and things
like that so yeah it was growing up over
the summer but that was intentional
um I mean no further action is is sort
of proposed there now that we've tied
down where the responsibility is and if
there are any particular concerns then
they can be referred through to
Sanctuary housing okay that's good to
interrupt you here please uh with the
Boston Avenue I know that we I know that
we've been in contact with Sanctuary
housing but it's beyond that that their
their jurisdiction is that uh where
um it does tend to back up
um and I wonder if anything can be done
Beyond The Sanctuary housing
um region is would would the uh the
diamond close issue which would seem to
be related to a bank slip
um have anything to do with that Chris
or Jeff
it could could very well be could very
well be I mean I know there is uh I know
that I've been down there myself to have
a look and and I mean I'm no expert as
you as you can understand but there
there are problems Beyond sanctuaries uh
jurisdiction yes okay towards that end I
mean obviously we've got um the
developers original developers Bell
white
um anything on diamond close at all Jeff
that you've been able to
get information on please uh yes this is
um
again been trying to sort of track down
responsibilities and and all the links
and things there
um
the discussions are now taking place
between
the landowners uh which is uh king
um kingly Grange
um which is is sort of it's it's like a
sort of local residence Association
um that that uh who obviously are not
really in the position to undertake some
of this work
so they're talking with belway who are
the original developers
um and they're trying to come to some
sort of agreement between them
um as to to what can be done and who can
do it and who pays for it and all this
sort of thing
um so really sort of on ongoing uh
ongoing discussions on that one thank
you
yeah no I know Bill way of uh sort of
done a little in the way of fencing it
off making it safe and what have you but
nevertheless I I do understand what Jeff
is saying and and um
that they seem to the residents seem to
think that this is their sort of under
management contract that they should be
doing but you know that's where the
differences of opinion are and I
understand that I understand that
totally
um again it's responsibilities isn't it
it is uh okay Grove Road
um yeah
this is angry and water I know what it
is the pumping it I mean this is a big
problem where growth Road and houses got
flooded uh in 2013 and uh there was
there is a lack of capacity which I
believe uh has been acknowledged the
whole way through
um there should be a new pumping model
or a new uh pumping section to actually
because they're not going to put in new
pipes to increase the capacity but they
want to try and increase the flow is
what I understand
um any update because where I was told
it was 2020 then 2021 2022 we've nearly
finished 2022 and nothing still happened
uh anything at all Jeff
uh no I must admit I'm uncited on this
one uh
I would normally ask for an update
before the for the meeting but I seem to
have missed this one I'll ask for an
update from England water yeah uh Mark
Francois was chasing this one a long
long time ago and had a word with them
you know this was promised
um
20 21 and then it went to 2022 we've now
nearly finished that so you know if you
can look into that be much obliged that
one end is about five or six years old
isn't it it is well it went back to the
flooding of 2013. Chris yep yeah
another one that uh is in ancient books
yeah again it's it's one that I've uh
sort of carried forward from the uh from
the old notes yeah so that so that it's
sort of captured but I'll try and get
something more up to date on that yeah I
think it's important that we're Rayleigh
Hills and the Israeli Hills because
you've got the Eastwood Eastwood Road
which is a high point and then it dips
all the way down as it goes down
Clarence into Grove Road Grove Road is
basically the lower level uh it's one of
the uh the lower levels and
unfortunately everything falls down to
there and of course the capacity is over
capacity now so uh that's the problem
with that particular area they know what
it is they know what they need to do
they're just not doing it at the moment
um anyway if we can carry on I believe
it's for us I think this was uh London
Road Church Road
yes and that that was the um comments
that the councilor Stanley was was
making yeah yeah the sort of progress on
there
um the discussions with the um
uh they're all worth flood Action Group
basically
we've agreed away forward for sort of
short and medium tone short medium and
long-term improvements
um some of which are sort of already
underway for the short term
um so so yes good progress on that one
section
yeah go on thank you um yeah just to
mention that we are looking at 19
1895 floodplains
um planes uh of watercourses
um obviously since then 1895 obviously
it's been built up since then and and
there are obviously viaducts and and
other Subterranean areas where it's been
over built over and there we've got to
try and find a way around those areas
which have been built onto so Chris
would you be so kind as to send that
information to David Chapman please I I
was just going to say that um we could I
could send that off to him as his uh
Essex yes yeah thank you very much
indeed for that Chris very useful uh
Swain Park Jeff
uh yeah the the last information I had
was in September where the drains were
actually in the process of being
installed
um so I guess that's a question of
monitor that over the winter and see how
effective that is that's great Eastwood
Road
oh this is well I I've I've been dealing
with this since well I didn't do I knew
it all started in 2008 I had to pick it
up in 2014.
um this is a big problem
um we're gonna need some help on this
because there there are documents uh
from Essex County Council when the work
was done
stating that the works would be done up
to adaptable standard that's what was
promised there is an issue going on with
Essex County Council legal team the
documents original documents that I was
able to share with Sean Scranton when we
brought this up originally he sent them
to Essex County Council
and have they have lost the documents uh
very sad this I've been able to contact
a resident
who has a full record but he hasn't
allowed he hasn't let me have the
document yet which actually states that
very that very point that um it was
going to be made up to adoptable
standard they did put a lot of money
into this a lot of residents and that
was the promise that this work was going
to be done
um Essex does not clear the drains
there's no lighting there's nothing
there
um it's pretty lousy in the area the
drainage is shocking
um so now there's a big problem here
which I'm aware of Jeff probably more
than you are
and and again I think this is as it says
Essex County Council legal team this is
a legal angle of admitting liability for
work that they've done and not actually
doing what they said they would do and
until I've I can get retrieve or get the
original paperwork which unfortunately
has been lost
um we're getting nowhere
so I think I think I've covered that one
I think I haven't I'll I'll update some
some notes so that that's cash please
please yeah
that's a bit of a message I'm gonna jump
in here again could we make could we
have a document of outstanding long-term
problems that have Arisen out of this
today's program of what we've done what
we've been talking about because yeah I
think for me that there is there's too
many and and they seem to be sort of
left on the back burner all the time
look Chris uh Christine bought this
exact point at the last meeting in the
minutes we've we've actually gonna
correct that to make sure that where we
see an issue we will put it literally
date it from first actual recorded uh
mention of it so yeah thank you for
reiterating that Chris thank you sorry
sorry I I mentioned it sorry no no
problem at all
um Hockley Road
[Music]
um so this is uh this is Riley Hockley
Road and that's opposite yeah yeah
there was a sort of report
um of flooding there
um highways of not uh had anything
reported I've not had anything reported
since
um I've been and had a look at it
um I mean unless anybody's a aware of
any particular issues around there and
and can give us some details we we've
not really got anything to work on well
well the issues occur a little bit
further down actually
um going towards hambrough Hill uh yeah
they tend to go that way where the water
tends to miss the drain and goes into
people's front Gardens uh that tends to
be enough scene it actually happened and
they've had to have sandbags there to
protect themselves uh I think this again
is an ongoing issue
for as long as I can remember we've had
the flood forum and I think you've heard
that as well Chris haven't you yes um
they've actually put in the the uh
drains on the curb what they well I
don't know what you quite call that
perforated uh curves or whatever you
like to call it
um and and that does happen I would
suggest would say that uh we had the
drains cleared at the top of the uh
Hockley Road as you rise up into Hockley
uh the drains were cleared there only
about three weeks ago now
um and the drains as far as I was aware
we had them cleared at the cemetery
um last was it last year or maybe the
year before it goes so quickly and there
is no problem there at that Cemetery
point if you like across Victoria
uh where have you
um but yes you are right there are
problems where the water actually Pours
Down off of the hill and it's coming
down at such a torrent unfortunately it
rises over the curb and jump straight
into people's front Gardens yeah I don't
know I don't know how you can you can
divert it or anything like that or have
it a club I think it's the slope of the
road unfortunately it falls towards the
gardens and away from the drainage it's
just always constructive it's just one
of those things unfortunately I think
they've been looking into it for a long
time
um if you can just keep that one uh on
the go so we're constantly looking at it
Roger welcome nice to see you yeah sorry
about that I was at a meeting another
meeting
don't worry we've saved up a few things
for you so yeah thank you very much
thank you
uh so Hockley Road
um we're we're no further forward on
that one then Jeff yeah
uh no but I'll I'll make a more sort of
accurate note of what the issues are and
this is this is sort of part of of the
process is is sort of finding out
and and defining what the issues are so
that we can then share that more
accurate accurately with Partners
point out to you Jeff that a drain has
been completely what was uh a drain on
the hambrough hillside
um is now defunct it's been taken out of
commission and uh been tarmacked over
um I wonder if um yes you're quite right
there Ian to pull that face because I
was quite surprised myself obviously the
drain didn't work so they just told
macked over it blocked it completely
could we could we have could we have
anything done about that Jeff in in the
way of uh highways looking at those
problems of drainage on hambro Hill
so that that that's located actually on
the hambrough hill or is that still on
Hockley Road no that's on hambrow here
where the water actually comes down you
know off off the hill and come stand
into the Gully
um so that will come down to hambrow
Hill so uh where we're up sort of
adjacent to the land bricks and then
comes down after the lamb bricks yeah
yes yes correct yes okay thank you all
right okay so if we can position that
one that would be handy uh Victoria Road
Swain Court
and
yeah
um
where are we sorry just looking at this
yes
there's
um
I'm trying to sort of understand as far
as I can the the whole sort of area
because the uh
obviously the
the main problem is the fact it's a
low-lying area and the water all sort of
ends up there this is all part of the
London Road
a river
where I've seen it as a river you might
as well have had a boat down there at
one time I've never seen anything like
it and of course uh Victoria Road comes
off of that
um so it is low-lying I mean
and again I think what would be helpful
uh with Chris and these older Maps just
to give a good idea because the water
will always flow towards its original
exhaust and it will always try to follow
up find itself so it could be handy it
might it might enlarge our thinking and
especially if we're getting an expert
um I'm not saying you're not Jeff but uh
but so no I'm not I'm just saying
someone in who really does understand
these things a little bit better who can
help us to really nail down what we need
to do if we can do things yeah
so you know
I was just going to say there Ian we've
we've got uh streams underground streams
in Roy Flynn underground streams in
Victoria
um and as you was rightly pointed out
um off of London Road they all dive
underground uh and come up sort of
towards sanctuary and chief Side West oh
it's just unbelievable what there is
yeah yeah so I think that would help
Dave uh Chapman with regard to trying to
get this to get a better understanding
of of what you know all these various
tributors and streams are that would be
very helpful yeah thanks a lot so
um if we were to to look at that we say
it's related to the the topography I
think we we need to sort of keep this
one on the front burner so that when we
actually get a better investigative
point in and I wonder you know Roger as
well from environment I mean how much
you know uh you need to be able to see
where some of these streams are would it
be useful if some of these original uh
maps and streams are also shared with
you Roger
yes I can certainly have a look Ian yeah
because again I mean you you really do
need to know where they're coming from
where they're going to and the impact
they're going to have because again you
know if we're looking at our local plan
um I think this is going to come very
much to the Forefront of understanding
where we need to plan what we need to
mitigate and try to understand where the
problems are and we don't cause more
problems for ourselves in our local and
our new plans so that would be very
handy Roger we need to you know get knit
things together as best we can yep yep
okay lovely thanks a lot Roger uh wins
away
and
I think you know that was where we got
the gullies block drying I think this
has always been a problem which goes
down Grove Road
yeah and the smoking area
I think we're
it's been cleared
um it no defects were sort of reported
um I think we're just waiting to to to
see if there are any further issues uh
on that one okay uh I believe I've just
gonna want to note
um a thank you from Cheryl who asked me
to thank Angley and Walter uh in regards
to the Grove Road Tudor close which is
all the same is around Windsor why and
such like it's all off of there uh for
the work they've done in in clearing
stuff uh and the girl is so if you can
just make a note on that one please
okay okay
moving on to uh Rochford and Sutton road
as if I'm coming on that end yeah of
course you can Mike yeah the the I'm
still not happy with the report on the
issue there this
um issue was uh Essex County Council
forced the land owner this particular
ditch which he did a great expense and
it is a pretty big bit and deep dish
I've jokingly referred to it as a canal
but uh it's up to that sort of stand
the issue is that there is no outfall
for that through the school which is
right up adjacent to
and the ditch runs right along the edge
of the road
and cars quite regularly go over the
curve there
if the vehicle goes into that ditch it
is deep enough
to sink a car
with the amount of water that it holds
um it could cause a problem
um I'm sorry but I've got to keep on
about this it needs an outfall from that
h
into the river
it's a river Roach
I would suggest that it needs to go
under the road and picks up on the
Culvert that feeds into the river on the
other side of the road that's that's
probably the easiest way to do it rather
than going through the sea wall
so sorry but um you know no further
action there does need to be further
action to make that safe it is not safe
as it stands you've only got to look at
the curbs along that edge of the road
you can see they've all been dislodged
in the last year
uh since they put them back again
okay
um
I can certainly note that in past past
that that sort of comment on to uh to to
highways
um and uh see if they have any further
comment that's another one uh Mike
that's been going on for years it is it
has been going on what's considerable
time
um they've done surveys along there
about where the drains go and the drains
that are on the gullies of the road run
into this dude yeah they do
yeah so it fills up all the time exactly
it's full of water 24 7.
okay
um if I move on uh Ian road development
um there is ongoing discussions with the
developer with regards to the drainage
there
um it is
um there are still some issues
particularly for the properties that run
along the edge of the whole road
development uh in Oak Road uh and that's
where I picked up earlier on on that
Culvert that goes well Lane bike can you
just hang on a second uh I just want to
quickly go back
um uh to the Sutton road uh Roger if you
would just be so kind as to have a look
at that from an environment agency point
of view just to see what the
connectivity is with that flooding with
the ditch that is there uh does it and
if it's anything to do with the roach
and the connectivity with the roach can
you kind of work with Essex highways to
give your View on is there anything that
needs to be done or can be advised from
your side could you pick that up please
Roger
I'm not clearing what you want me to do
there
if I could come in there can I suggest
that Roger and I get together offline on
this particular Point yep so I can
explain to him in Greater date okay if
you could speak to Mike step go or my
stepco speaks to you with regard because
I think there seems to be some
connection if it's into the roach which
is basically environmental
responsibility there may be a case that
that they may say there's engineering
required to actually relieve this so
there may be monies or grants available
one way or another to actually get this
damn job done so I don't know but let's
look into it let's see if we can
actually get some action to actually
find a cure for it because it's been
ongoing too long sorry sorry Mike do you
want to go back to Hall Road if you just
take a note of that please Jeff
it is title that um on the other side of
the sea wall uh right yes with the whole
Road uh I did pick up on it earlier on
I'm still trying to identify who's
responsible for the missing slow skate
where the Culvert Runs Out under iron
will lay into the other contributory to
the roach
um
uh the flap is missing so the water
could back up through the system so
that's a concern there
um
again with the Rochford 100 golf club
that all feeds into the same point
um with the with the streams that's
another tributary to the roach yeah
that's all feeds into there so I don't
know if there's any update on that Jeff
uh no I mean really as you say that all
links together the
um in terms of the Rochford hundred Golf
Club the the flooding there
I mean we
that could potentially be part of the
solution rather than a problem
um uh as looking at the whole of the
hawkwell brook
um but as I was saying earlier it needs
somebody with a
yeah a a more relevant knowledge than I
have to to sort of bring that project
together and look at that
um but as I say it could be a water
storage on the golf course could be a a
possible
um benefit rather than a problem and I
think technically the golf course is the
floodplain of that area but of course
you've got to be careful there how far
that goes that will lead straight into
the end of the runway at Southend
airport yeah yeah absolutely uh West
Street
uh West Street yes there's has been an
ongoing problem
um along the back edge of the path in
West Street uh the pavement there is
like a well I won't call it a gully it's
not deep enough to be a gully but
there's a shaping in the pavement that
is supposed to direct the water away
from the doorways
it doesn't work in high rain volume
areas and basically water just goes in
through the front doors
so I think there still needs to be some
uh work done there to to improve that
um way that water is taken away from the
properties the pavement itself
it's back towards the properties it
needs to be reprofiled it tips towards
the road
yeah thank you David I understand you've
got to go
um now
um is there anything in place that we
can make higher Curts
and I know some I know some areas
because of flooding they've solved a
problem-ish by making the curbs higher
trying to interrupt you right Ian in
this case it needs to be the opposite
way the curve needs to be lowered to
enable the water on the pavement to run
onto the road okay fair enough okay
thanks for that Mike okay moving on to
the wakeres yeah I'm sure councilman
McPherson will pick up on this but I
will pick up on one particular item in
the High Street Great Waverly there is a
property rough or Road properties
roughly opposite the old school where
the front doors are right up on the
pavement
there is no the vaccinate the door steps
go on to the Pavements yeah there is a
ripping the road there I'll wear water
collects it does drain away reasonably
quickly but that's not the problem
this is quite a large puddle
what happens is the vehicles come
through splash the water up and it goes
straight through the front doors of the
listed buildings
where the puzzle is there in effect the
residents cannot use their front door
no no no no it's uh
there's there's no hallway the front
door leads leads straight into the
lounge yeah the fact that he's probably
probably what needs to happen there is
that the road needs to be re-profiled so
the water runs away to the gullies a lot
quicker okay okay so uh Jeff
you've heard you've heard that problem
Joe what do you want to add to it
darling Oh yeah quite a bit
um okay um just so that um Jeff can
complain the attack Terrier of um some
of it's opposite as uh councilor step
towards just pointed out the old school
it's between number 773 is it that I
said Mike because it's it's 71 or 73 I
can't remember exactly yeah 73 to about
83 so there is um quite a dip where a
flood
um now the other one which is the one
that's here on the document uh those uh
unless I'm wrong um
Jeff you met with the landowners in
August for them to start working
September
where are we now have we got a date
um no I did uh I did try and follow up
with them before this this meeting but
uh didn't get a reply so I'll have to
follow up with them
um they couldn't do it before September
yeah we knew that but
um yes they haven't given me a a date or
notified me of anything they're doing as
I said I tried to chase that but
couldn't get hold of anybody okay um
can can I um put something forward and
chairman perhaps you can take this up
um if the landowners aren't doing this
within the next say six weeks because
I'm sorry look at the weather out there
now
um and it's only going to get worse
can we take action
and then build them retrospectively for
the work because you can see what the
weather's like today there's if anything
keeps getting worse
okay okay Joe deadly silence no no not
from me as far as I'm concerned there's
there's so many different things that
are going on that we need to understand
what should be done and what isn't being
done
um yeah if we can look into that and and
Andrew uh if I just bring you in on this
one I know this could be a legal issue
but you know if we do work
and then we retrospectively Bill the
responsible person because I haven't
done the work can you look at the
implications on that and that is if we
can yes we will and if there are
problems then we have to understand the
problems thank you very much for that
Joe but you know there's a lot a lot of
this stuff that goes on that gets left
we're leaving it and if we decide to
take the bull by the horns and say right
okay if you don't do it we're going to
do it and we will we will put our people
in there to do it and you'll get billed
are you happy with that and if they're
happy with that that's fine the work
gets done and they pay for it yeah okay
um so if that can be done as a matter of
urgency and somebody let me know so I
can advise um our residents and also the
junction of the High Street in this way
it can Road there's a roundabout there
as my except I will know
um when it rains it floods there now
what we have had recently is a house
that had a very large garden
has actually made a substantial driveway
now
so
it's only going to make the situation
worse I'm just waiting to see this
happen
um what if anything can we do as a local
Authority about this
um I I was under the understanding if it
was non-porous there should be some sort
of planning consent and perhaps soak
aways put in
um and is this something that we could
investigate further as the flood Forum
because I can only foresee this problem
getting worse as more and more people
are putting their cars on their
driveways this is a this is a planning
issue yeah
as opposed to a flooding issue although
used to both yeah okay yeah okay
um Jeff if you can just make a note on
that to see uh exactly what they've done
and how they're going to go about it if
you can manage that one please Jeff yeah
the the if I can make a couple of
comments on on some of those
um
just to finish off on the West Street
one the the the uh there was a comment
from the highways agency they they have
um sent an ad hoc team out and done uh
sort of cleaning of all the drains so it
it should all work as it as it should
um so it'd be interesting to hear if
there are still further problems which
is quite likely I I agree given the way
that the the the Pavements are facing
um but we can feedback on that may I
just come in on that what doesn't help
is when they do come out clear all the
drains are absolutely perfect and then
you've got one of our utilities out
where I have to shout from my car as I'm
waiting at traffic light please don't
Sweep All That luck in concrete down the
drain
okay yeah we have mentioned that
previously to
um two highways
um in terms of legal action
um for where maintenance is required on
ditches and things like that
there are
uh
yes the the there is you can take legal
action and you can do as you say
um
uh undertake the work and then charge
the the landowners
um
we don't really have anybody in the
council who is able to do that at the
moment
um and I I think it does get very
difficult very complicated is
my understanding is it's very very
rarely done okay although they need
local flood Authority could assist us
with that
um if if we wanted to sort of go on that
route okay so can I just if I could come
in come in
hang on Mike hang on
um we've got Andrew here
um I think Andrew can take this bit back
to see where we go go on Mike I'm saying
I believe this has come up before in
very early days of that Forum that the
responsibility of issuing uh enforcement
notice let's call it that uh
irresponsibility of County rather than
District
yeah I I think that I think that was the
case I do remember that being said but I
think we need to readdress this because
uh I'm afraid County doesn't do very
much it would seem at times uh with all
due respect and so if there is something
that we can do from our end to be a wee
bit more proactive I think you've got to
agree that it would be it would be
better
um if we could if we could go about it
that way so it might be worth looking
into to see what we can do because we're
you know sometimes not so easy getting
County to do stuff although I would
suggest that perhaps it's about to be
taken up with the portfolio holder which
in this case is casually
yeah okay that's lovely thank you
um
in here with with that uh driveway
um I do believe it is a planning issue
and they should ask for planning
permission for that driveway to be uh uh
erected
um I've had one in my own uh world where
the driveway was not permeable and they
did not put any subsequent drainage in
for that and they had to take it I sent
our enforcement uh Team over they
checked it made sure that they was
getting putting in uh drainage for that
driveway so that is enforceable yes okay
Joe if you can just send an email to me
and to enforcement in regards to that
one and we'll see if we can do this on a
different route
an enforcement officer that has the time
oh I I know what you're saying I know
what you're saying but no we we will we
will see what we can do we can only see
what we can do I think Andrew is
listening very intently to all these
conversations
um to see because we do need to upgrade
our enforcement to have more officers
out there because well I believe you're
doing ons as well so as far as
nice to mention that one this is a
comment on that one on drives
um it was something I I asked about just
to sort of help understand it and the um
off the top of my head I think it's
anything over 50 square meters uh as a
drive
um should be put in with uh should ask
for planning permission and and should
put in uh a permovable surface you're
correct
um but I understand from the local lead
the local flood Authority that um
I don't think anybody within Essex has
ever
um sort of uh enforce that okay could I
just ask a question around that if it's
an existing driveway and the driveway is
upgraded
does that still apply
yeah it's a new driveway
from what I understand from Air
enforcement team
let's move let's move back into the
flood area if we can go on to bowling
Road near the old shoulder stick and
that time to my knowledge has now been
resolved I've not had any further uh
issues from that particular Point uh
there's been some resurfacing by the
road there so the profiles of the road a
lot better
and the various landowners have made
improvements around that so I think uh
at this stage I think we could probably
let that one drop off the system okay
have you got that one Veronica that can
disappear okay Kimberly Road
a dip Kimberly Road this is this is an
interesting one the uh I think Council
Affairs will want to come in on this as
well the where the um Watercourse runs
underneath a a small driveway
um under the and then under the sea wall
there is a grill there
uh now the risk the end of Kimberly Road
which is adopted by ISIS County Council
stops at the Stream
so I would question whether Essex County
Council is one of the riparian
landowners
certainly as far as that part of the
stream is concerned keeping the the
undergrowth clear is the responsibility
on behalf of Essex by Rochford District
Council
um so I would question whether there is
perhaps a riparian ownership by assets
counter Council on making sure that this
Gully is kept clear and improvements to
that side of the city wall the other
side of the sea wall has been improved
has been a new Seascape put in there
that build one it was put in ice I can't
remember I think it was environmental
agency or anything wasn't it okay you
know his environment agency here yeah
thank you very much indeed Roger Jeff
you're taking a note of that on primary
Road
uh yes yeah in fact we've uh Roger and I
and and others did a visit there just to
sort of try and understand what was
going on and what was was was happening
um
yes there is this question around the
the sort of Maintenance and the uh
Improvement Works to uh a sort of grill
and things like that yes historically
Rochester District Council has has done
that
um but I need to sort of follow up on
who and how and and what really on that
okay if I could come just come back in
on that point I think you'll find Jeff
that the responsibility of that was
from Russia's point of view prior to the
requirement being handed over to Essex
County Council in dealing with flood
issues
okay thank you very much for changing
legislation wasn't there from District
to account Council yeah thanks a lot
Mike
okay so you've you we've got this in
hand so it's going to be maintenance
ongoing maintenance yes Jeff
uh yes yeah that there's
um the
yes a number of sort of issues around
that most of which are seem to be
resolved apart from this ongoing
maintenance side of things okay and can
you identify the lead agency again
please try to find it
this is one of these things where it's
uh a differently is it a joint venture
yes very much okay if we could have that
down it does help
lovely thank you very much for the last
item uh Pointer's Line waitering Road I
just very quickly I didn't know where
the council Professor wouldn't come in
on that particular point because
increases our two wards okay
I think you've covered everything Mike
okay yeah thank you
okay yes pointers Lane is the junction
of Point pointers Lane and wakery Roads
yep there were some
um improvements put in place by the
um
perfect management team
part of that originally was to look at
the improvements to the sight lines
coming out of that juncture because the
ditches there are constantly overgrowing
this is tree fella isn't it on that
corner well yes one side is tree fella
the other side is mod
oh just to make it easy thank you the
the it's more on the side of the mod
side of it that it is an ongoing
constant problem that the growth coming
out of those ditches uh firstly are
blocking the ditches and flooding the
road and secondly blocking the sight
lines of that Junction and bearing in
mind that pointers Lane is a 60 mile an
hour road yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
so
um I think this is a if it's mod just uh
a letter to an old either my period
owner on that side to clear their to
clear their site yes that would be to
kinetic rather than the magnetic yeah
yeah I know who is sugary and all the
rest of it okay now that's fine okay
um just want to go back on something uh
with Roger I think we did make a note
didn't we Jeff uh without
um well no I mean Roger is a environment
I'm not anglian you know so we can't be
is there anything uh that we had for the
environment agency Jeff that was left
over I'm just going back through my
notes I think there was something that
we thought oh we can ask Roger that when
you arrived yep
um what was it
sorry going back through my notes I
can't find it now
yeah and at this point I'm going to
leave thank you very much no thank you
very much indeed Lorraine is that just
forever just before you go I know you've
got a dash is there anything that you
want to comment on at all or are you
happy with everything no it's fine I'll
let Lee know that there's going to be
some comments to come okay thank you
very much thank you Laurie bye bye
bye-bye
and now I can't I can't find anything it
was we had something specifically for
England water which I'll follow up on
okay
um I don't think there was anything
specific for for Roger but I can ask him
subsequently if I find what it was okay
is there anything Roger that you want to
put into the Forum at all that's that's
upcoming and going that you're looking
at within the area that that we need um
yeah I'm just wondering whether we had
an inquiry in about
um some defenses from Andrews and Joseph
it's not that is it
well I I have no knowledge of that I'm
sorry no okay
um that's the only other thing I've
gotten in and also I've had something in
from counselor
Crips
oh yes yeah go on about uh where are we
which I've passed that up
Kingsley Grange
um yes yes we have gone through that one
uh earlier on
um was that the item you were looking
for Jeff Kingsley Grange
I think it was it was the one where
we've got the management that are
looking into it with belway yeah this is
a management company
[Music]
um yeah with bellway yeah yeah so
councilor Crips has uh sent through an
inquiry to the EA which has been logged
onto the system and has gone to our
operations team for comments okay all
right so
that's the only other thing the only
thing I'm working on is uh Dave Chapman
and I have still working on the wick
Country Park slowing the flows Upstream
of Church Road so that's so yeah
interurora yep yep uh we're meeting with
some landowners tomorrow actually okay
Dave and I to see whether we can get
some further buy-in on that okay that's
good that's good and from what I
understand the um well maybe councilor
Stanley can tell me but they're clearing
out the uh
the main river down there Church Road
Bridge they're dig silt in I don't know
whether that work has started
maybe councilor Stanley knows
yeah the work uh with reference to that
the the work has started
um unfortunately the machine that's in
there is uh somewhat excessive in way of
uh its volume its largeness and it can't
get in to do some of the operations that
need to be done we need to get smaller
machine in however
um
from what I understand uh there's only
going to be 40 meters of clearance to
the stream
um and we will be looking for a further
75 meters to be cleared to the bend of
the uh River of the uh Royce Brook uh so
that it gets down to the past the bend
in other words so that it gets round
there and then flows into the crowd so
right we'll be looking we will be
looking to you Roger for that um uh if
you like authority to to do that later
on and that will come that will come
after David as has done his project okay
yeah thank you thank you I'm conscious
of time gentlemen and I was going to say
here and that's all I've got really okay
that's fantastic uh just coming on from
that
um Andrew's with us today I just want to
quit I didn't get a chance to introduce
him earlier he's the interim director of
people and governance uh for both uh the
borough of uh Brentwood and for RDC for
the one one team we're going to have a
review of the flood forum and how it
works and if we can improve it uh
there's a few things that I would like
to see improved
um Christine you want to come in
foreign
I did ask this to be put on on the
agenda
um
I'm sure we're all pleased to say that
uh some of the concerns have been
alleviated resolved or concluded
[Music]
however
following the concerns that I raised
about the lack of progress and
resolutions in some cases over 12 years
blue councilman Pearson actually pointed
out one in her area it was agreed that
we would
undertake a review which was sent to the
overview of the scopely committee in
March
a working group under the overview of
scrutiny
is due to report to them on the terms of
reference in December
so this is just make sure that
everyone's aware of what's going on
however a number of discussions I've had
with councilor Watson have concluded
that the process the strategy and the
governance needs to be refreshed bearing
in mind this forum was set up in 2014
and we wanted to see an efficient use of
the resources that we have to maximize
Speedy resolutions
the winter with the associated weather
and greater risk of flooding upon us and
I'm sure we're all aware of the great
distress costs that flooding causes
and I'm pleased to inform you that the
leader has asked officers to arrange a
meeting
so the way forward on how flooding
issues are managed and addressed in the
district
is going to take place and hopefully
this will take place in the very near
future certainly before the end of the
year and I think that's quite positive
that we though we're not a flood of
authority we are doing the best we can
for our residents in difficult
circumstances and we need to get good
cooperation from the other authorities
so that the
effort that we put in as counselors and
the effort that our officers spend is
done efficiently so that's why our set
to be put on here just so that everyone
could know what was going on thank you
well that's so thank you very much
Christine I I absolutely agree with you
um as I was saying earlier on it it's
it's really useful if all the various
um authorities and utilities that
actually service our area or at the
meeting and I I really do appreciate the
fact that Roger is here you know
um you know I know it's not easy
disappointed that Essex highways were
not able to be here but I believe there
were reasons but I would wish that they
would make an effort to come and Anglia
water uh Essex you know all the various
players within our area need to be in
here to be able to actually come back
with the follow-ups to questions that
are sub subsequent to to to to the
various questions that are going to be
asked and I'm glad that Andrew's here
because I believe Andrew you will be
involved in this uh particular uh review
and looking at things I just put the
over to you uh yes I will so so I'm
going to be looking at all the uh
Governors Arrangements across uh both
both councils looking to see you know
whether he was actually going at the
moment uh what needs to be reviewed and
what needs to be improved and uh yeah
with regard to this one I think
councilman Mason has summed it up very
well you know we know there is limited
resources they need to be focused
um uh a case of the war talk about the
need to knit things together uh early on
and I think that's exactly right and so
you know I I think there's a piece of
work to be done to say right these are
the resources that we've got what we can
what can we actually do what do we need
to focus on to actually make uh you know
the difference that's required
um and so I'll be looking at that from a
Governor's point of view but I think
also we need uh the the people such as
you know as Roger and David and Jeff so
that we can actually talk about the
resources that we've actually got as
well so yes I've got an email from
um the leader asked me to set at that
meeting and that is what I'll do and
take things forward lovely thank you
very much indeed uh Mike
and oh sorry Christy no Mike
you've got your hand up
are you with us Mike
I'm gonna have to move on because we're
coming out sorry about it um yes the
couple of points I wanted to remind
members of one is that there is a
meeting of the Essex flood Forum uh on
the 2nd of December
uh I shall be in attendance to that as a
member of that uh secondly when there
are flooding issues particularly on the
highways please members and it could be
any member of the public can report it
make sure that it gets reported on the
reporting tool uh it is important that
that is done uh through the Essex
highways
um
website
and thirdly I think we need to have a
far greater of greatness to Andrew a far
greater understanding on who is
responsible for enforcement action over
land owners uh because we all know
landowners will try and duck their
responsibilities uh equally as much
I would also add to that that when
legal teams are looking to do the
searches for purchases or properties to
make sure that the information for
riparian ownership of ditches around
properties are highlighted within those
searches I've come across a number of
occasions where people have bought a
property and do not know they are
responsible for the ditch that runs
around the outside of their Garden
correct yeah yeah that's a very good
point there Mike Mike I'm gonna have to
start winding this session up because I
know other members have got meetings to
go to I certainly do very very shortly
um there are no questions from the
public
um I believe Veronica
there's none at all thank you very very
much
um any other business from anybody we've
got for a few minutes is there anything
else that anybody wants to to bring
forward here otherwise I'd like to thank
you interesting
I would just very quickly like to
endorse what Chelsea sector has said
about the searches I think that's a very
very valid point and I could assure him
that it's it's not generally done or it
wasn't in the past so I think that's
um something that we could certainly
improve on thank you
right uh Jeff uh and all members
um I would like to thank you all for
attending uh we've got through this
within our time limit which I'm always
pleased to see and so again I'd like to
thank you all for attending and taking
part and I wish you all a very good day
thank you very much I'd like to thank
you Ian for conducting this chairmanship
of the flood Forum I think it's gone
ever so well and thank you Chris I would
like to see you do it again if you don't
mind please
if someone was to put if someone wants
to stick me here I don't mind no it's
another job for you anyway thank you
very much indeed goodbye okay all the
best to you thank you very much indeed
bye bye